[Music]
muscles
and joints shift and jostle the heart's
pounding rhythm speeds up
blood roars through the arteries and
veins over the course of a pregnancy
every organ in the body changes ignited
by a range of hormones
these changes begin as soon as pregnancy
begins
just days after fertilization the embryo
implants in the lining of the uterus
because its dna
doesn't exactly match the mothers the
immune system should theoretically
recognize it as an invader
attack and destroy it like it would
bacteria
or other harmful microbes that's the
challenge
the mother's immune system needs to
protect both her
and the fetus but can't act as it
usually does
what happens is not as simple as
decreasing the immune response
instead it's a complex interaction
we're just beginning to understand
involving many different types of immune
cells
some of which seem to protect the fetus
from attack by
other immune cells
the body also creates an antibacterial
plug made of mucus on the cervix
which keeps germs away and stays sealed
until labor
as pregnancy progresses the uterus
expands upward and outward with the
growing fetus
to make room hormones called
progesterone and relaxin
signal muscles to loosen the muscles
that propel
food and waste through the digestive
tract also loosen
which makes them sluggish causing
constipation as
passage through the tract slows down
loosened muscles at the top of the
stomach might allow
acid to escape into the esophagus and
throat causing heartburn and reflux
these changes can worsen morning
sickness which is caused in part by the
hormone
hcg and can also happen at other times
of day
as the uterus grows it pushes on the
diaphragm the muscle that expands and
contracts
the chest with each breath this limits
the diaphragm's
range to compensate the hormone
progesterone acts as a respiratory
stimulant
making the pregnant woman breathe faster
so both she
and the baby can both get enough oxygen
with less
lung capacity this all may leave the
pregnant woman feeling short of breath
meanwhile the kidneys make more
erythropoietin
a hormone that increases red blood cell
production
the kidneys also keep extra water and
salt rather than filtering it out into
urine to build up the volume of the
blood
a pregnant woman's blood volume
increases by 50 percent or
more but it's also a bit diluted because
it only has 25
more red blood cells usually the body
makes blood cells using iron from our
food
but during pregnancy the fetus is also
building its own blood supply from
nutrients in the mother's food
leaving less iron and other nutrients
for the mother
the heart has to work extra hard to pump
all this blood through the body
and placenta a pregnant woman's heart
rate increases
but we don't fully understand how blood
pressure changes in a healthy pregnancy
an important area of research because
some of the most
serious complications are related to the
heart and blood pressure
the expanding uterus may press on veins
causing fluid buildup in the legs and
feet
if it presses on a large vein called the
inferior vena cava
it might interfere with blood returning
to the heart
causing a dizzying drop in blood
pressure after standing for too long
some of these changes start to reverse
even before
birth shortly before delivery the fetus
drops down
decreasing the pressure on the diaphragm
and allowing the pregnant woman to take
deeper breaths during labor and birth
much of the extra fluid in the body is
lost when the water breaks
the uterus shrinks back down in the
weeks after birth
like the rest of the body pregnancy
affects the brain
but its effects here are some of the
least understood
recent studies show differences in the
brain scans after pregnancy
and early parenting and suggests that
these changes are adaptive
that means they could help with
parenting skills such as an
increased ability to read facial cues
since babies can't talk
the lack of information about
pregnancy's effects on the brain
highlights a general truth historically
almost all the research around pregnancy
has focused on the fetus
rather than the pregnant women
experiences of pregnancy vary widely
both within the range of healthy
pregnancies and due to complicating
health conditions
new research will help us understand why
and develop
effective treatments where necessary in
the meantime
every pregnancy is different and it's
important to consult a doctor with any
specific
questions today we're
turning an exciting corner as more
research is devoted to the astounding
biology of
pregnancy in the last
40 years more than 5 million babies
have been born using in vitro
fertilization
so how does that work check out this
video to learn the fascinating science
behind
ivf
[Music]